Between group variability should be the numerator, because as it increases.
This will increase the whole test statistic, and this leans more in favor of
the alternative hypothesis, that at least one pair of means is significantly
diffferent. Within group variability should be the denominator, because as this
increases the f ratio decreases, which you can see algebraically. If the
denominator increases then the whole quotient will decrease. And this leans
more in the favor of the null hypothesis that the means are not significantly
different. Just like the t statistic the numerator indicates much group means
differ. This is explained variation. Because it most likely results from
differences due to a treatment. Or just differences in the populations. With
the clothing example from the beginning of the lesson, the difference in the
numerator can be explained by the fact that the clothes are from different
brands. But the denominator is a measure of error. Within-group variability
measures individual differences of subjects within each group. This is
considered error variation because we don't know why subjects in the same group
are different, whether they're people or shirts. They just are.